hello walk out this video playing I said
the Grand Master may be Detroit he's
don't know the first name this is
Grandmaster Veera Ronaldo or something
like that
right now though I am international
Grandmaster from Cuba okey-dokey let's
see yeah where does he go with the stems
oh you three let's see 92 or Bishop d3
lady - ok 3 yeah this is actually
slightly questionable I've played that
move myself once at a tournament game
forgetting about this the rook the rook
on h1 it's not it's not like terribly
bad for white but it is yeah
not what you was thinking of when you
played played this opening that you
would have to play rook g1 so so early
on okay okay a queen is attacked where
to put it
hmm not sure maybe if five was the five
attend to quickly Ted too early that's
the right word
we were to put that Queen Queen a five
now that's better as a three
hmm yeah I don't like it that much
something something was wrong maybe if I
was to quickly play anyway it's not that
it's not terrible or anything but I had
some other ideas here about this jack
hey let's take this to cover cover c7
now maybe you should take Lindy for no
if I was hanging that he cannot do Matt
should be okay what the place is six
kicked that night out it couldn't be six
was a move now that I think of it but
that doesn't look it doesn't look too
bad
[Music]
96
yeah I don't know night coming to the
six study awkward maybe let me do this
so that a six 934 is not playable he
even it's not so easy for him if he
castles loan for example Bishop f5
yeah Bishop f5 is a is an awkward
looking move
k1c one doesn't feel so comfortable
[Music]
you have maybe eight and then a six
should be okay
right before it's also interesting
[Music]
trying to arrest them even more than
that diagonal its interested interesting
but also I mean just a six it's not bad
able to your play ninety-four this is
not it's not so
so what terrible of him I wonder if I
should should go for and can go for for
more him
he succeeds good but is it the best I
also have f3 but he's got pawn to f3
which is not helping much
okay I'll go Asics to spend too long for
that move
[Music]
okay I am I can't actually take the
phone there is nothing nothing wrong
with the move I think I can move the
commune do I have a good square Queen a5
or something
well so what keeping going maybe - D -
it's not that not that great okay check
covering the eighth-ranked and now he's
got 95 coming huh
should I should have thought about that
it's it's bad
yeah but on the other hand if he goes 95
I places 697 where is he going with that
piece there's no squares to go to
[Music]
okay but I cannot play ok booty-eight is
kind of all my money it's kind of
awkward
this is hanging at the rook c5 I have to
be careful though that he doesn't get
that you found four rook e8 f 4 I
probably play look if I am NOT rook c5
should be three okay for rookie one
that's really awkward
rookie one remarkable
it cannot play that after okey one I
have no move
[Music]
yeah this should be should be okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm awfully sick at the moment I don't
really know what that is it's called ruk
f it maybe I can take the goofy one haha
stupid stuff check check check
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not going to for draw anything I'm
so totally winning earlier what for it's
on time anyway ah yeah okay that was
first of all that opening here the g3
move is really imprecise I played that
myself once with white and then my
opponent played t5 and hmm I recognized
that this wasn't a particularly great
idea
yeah root G 1 & 5 that looks normal
we should be too I went back that janky
okay and he still suffers from that lack
of coordination 96 so the other engine
says I'm completely winning here but I
didn't prove it so easily Bishop g4 is
better okay there should be 2 T and hmm
yeah make some sense all this comes with
with tempo Jack yeah Bishop g4 was even
stronger twin c5 now is also winning
directly and this is not that great so
this is stronger yeah the thing is
probably a night before all this knowing
this Jack okay this is also an idea
so Bishop g4 was stronger and yeah I'm
winning this pawn queen a5 was also
possible jack
yeah and now now I playing this really
badly in this position is just clearly
balanced was out this is what I meant
with at the end of the game I was so
winning this is just a pawn for nothing
black should win pretty easily but I'm
playing this is quite badly now this is
too keen to move should probably play a
King f8 or h5 or something he he
shouldn't get this yeah that that g4
stuff that gives him some some kind of
some kind of play and here this is
already a little bit a little bit
difficult to play even though
objectively speaking yeah it's it's it's
Co is a complete win I just have to play
rupees seven here and then g6 King g7
and the other night is strapped but even
the way I played it another computer
gives me keeps on your complete winner
yeah I just I just stumbled into to that
then did business you're only six I
should play weekly five nah not this
it's all get too late Jan yeah yeah I
don't know I can also take on b3 which
still cash on okay Jan yeah can't do
that sir it's a time it's a time issue I
have lost so many games on time in in
from Windsor I'm kind of tired of being
mr. nice guy then offered Ross or
whatever they they basically never do
the same so just be no time and get get
it over with okay thanks for watching